All right.
Hi, I'm Melissa Merritt. I'll be introducing today's session on
precision prevention.
And today we have a really great mix of talks from speakers that are
covering different areas in the precision prevention
spectrum.
In the area of risk assessment, our speakers will be
talking about the use of cytomorphologic signatures to
detect subsequent breast cancer risk.
We have a speaker that will present some new findings using liquid
biopsies to measure cell-free DNA to detect
precursors to hepatic cancer.
And we have another speaker who'll be talking about the molecular underpinnings of
colorectal adenomatosis polyposis in
cases where the usual drivers of this
disease are not present.
We also are focusing on some methodological advances with
potential to improve screening and early detection.
And in this area, we'll be having speakers talking about
screening for breast cancer using some new proteomics technology,
which would work better for women with dense breasts where mammography isn't
currently working as well.
And we have a speaker who will talk about multi-omics predictive model for
early detection of pancreatic cancer.
Last but not least, we also have some talks which are relevant for the
cancer survivor population. And one of the speakers will
talk about
the risk of developing secondary hematological malignancies
as a result of cancer treatment. And we also have a speaker
who's looking at breast cancer in Black women and
understanding how race and
exposure to poverty might influence the biology of this disease.
So I'm really looking forward to everyone's talk today, and
I would invite the first speaker up.
Is it Dr. Berneo?
I think it is Dr. Berneo. Well, Ms. Berneo.
Soon to be.
Yes. Soon to be a PhD. Okay. Welcome.
Thank you so much, Melissa, for the introduction.
And good afternoon, everyone.
I have no financial relationships to disclose.
So the number of cancer survivors is steadily increasing.
There are now over 18 million cancer survivors in the United
States, representing one in 18 Americans.
And that number is projected to increase to over 22 million by the year
2035.
Thanks to advances in early detection as well as treatment, many of these
individuals are living longer than ever before.
But with that success comes additional challenges.
Many of these cancer survivors are exposed to systemic therapies, which can have
lasting biological and genomic effects, contributing to an
increased risk of secondary hematologic malignancies.
And despite this, tools to identify those who are at
increased risk of secondary hematologic malignancies remain limited.
So one potential approach is through clonal hematopoiesis, or CH,
which is the age-related expansion of mutated hematopoietic clones.
One type of CH is clonal hematopoiesis of indeterminate
potential, or CHIP, which is characterized by somatic point mutations
or small insertions and deletions in leukemia driver genes.
Now, CHIP has been previously associated with an increased risk of hematologic
malignancies, and prior work has also suggested that cancer
therapies may selectively expand CHIP clones with
mutations, particularly those in DNA damage
response pathways, such as genes like TP53, PPM1D,
and CHEK2.
Another type of clonal hematopoiesis is mosaic chromosomal alterations,
or MCAs, which are larger structural
alterations that may result in copy number
gains, copy number losses, or copy neutral loss of heterozygosity.
Now, while MCAs have also been associated with an increased risk of
hematologic malignancies, their association with cancer therapy,
as well as their association with a risk of secondary hematologic
malignancy is less well understood.
And it is this gap in understanding that motivated our study.
So our study had two primary aims. First, to understand if exposure to
treatment promotes the acquisition or expansion of CH.
And second, to understand if treatment-related CH increases the
risk of secondary hematologic malignancies.
I've included this timeline here to orient you with the temporal
relationship that we'll include in this study.
So we leveraged data from 485,000
participants in the UK Biobank, 23,000 of whom
had a prevalent solid tumor. We're currently working on
classifying treatment exposure through the UK Biobank, but using these
operative procedure codes for specifically chemotherapy and radiation, we've
identified about 4,000 participants with known treatment.
So those analyses correspond to aim one,
and analyses comparing those individuals who go on to develop secondary
hematologic malignancies, and those
who develop or did not develop secondary hematologic
malignancies correspond to aim two.
So briefly, here is a table showcasing the breakdown of cancer types
within the prevalent solid tumor population.
Here I just want to emphasize that we did remove anyone who had a
prior hematologic malignancy.
So let's get into the results for our first aim, and the first two
points on this timeline. So we detected MCAs
using genotyping array data. So among those without a cancer,
3% had detectable autosomal MCAs.Among
those with a prior solid tumor, 4% had
detectable autosomal MCAs corresponded to an adjusted increase of
about 15%.
And then when looking at prior treatment, this frequency remained elevated,
corresponding to an adjusted increase of about 19%.
We then used adjusted logistic regression models to examine specific
associations to identify those specific MCAs that
may be enriched in cancer survivors, and
identified these copy neutral loss of heterozygosity events in
particular, that were associated with
cancer treatment as well as prevalent cancer.
So importantly, when we examine this forest plot here, you're seeing that
effect sizes generally increase when looking at prevalent
cancer, then comparing that to prevalent cancer and those who have known
chemo or radiation. These are just a small subset of our results,
but those that specifically highlight this pattern, suggesting
that exposure to cancer treatment does promote the expansion
of specific MCAs.
Performing the same analyses within CHIP,
we detected CHIP using sequencing data.
About 4.5% of participants without cancer had
detectable CHIP. This increased to 6.6% among
those with prior solid tumors, corresponding to an adjusted increase of about
20%.
And then looking among those with prior treatment, this increased to
7.5%, corresponding to an adjusted increase of about
50%. So while we're seeing a similar pattern to what we saw with the
MCAs, the elevation is a bit more pronounced for CHIP.
Examining specific mutations, again using adjusted
logistic regression, we are seeing a similar pattern where effect
estimates generally increase from prevalent cancer to those with
prevalent cancer as well as treatment.
And these genes that are specifically associated with
cancer treatment appear to be those that are
related to DNA damage response pathways.
So again, we are seeing that the CHIP mutations in these
genes may be
associated with treatment.
So to summarize the results of our first aim,
we see that CHIP is more strongly associated with therapy, and it is specific
events that are driving these associations, such as these loss of
heterozygosity MCAs, as well as CHIP mutations and DNA
damage response-related genes.
Now moving on to the second half of this presentation to look
at the
second two points on this timeline.
So among those individuals with only a solid tumor,
3.7% had autosomal MCAs, compared to
16.8% of those who develop a secondary hematologic
malignancy. And this corresponds to a hazards ratio of approximately
4.8%, suggesting that there is a substantially increased
risk of hematologic malignancy for those with any autosomal MCA.
Then using the same Cox model to examine specific events,
an important nuance emerges here.
If you think back to the prior forest plot that I shared with MCAs,
you might notice that the events shown here are actually not those events that
we talked about as being therapy-associated.
So for MCAs,
it appears that the therapy-associated events are not necessarily those
that are associated with hematologic malignancy development.
In fact, these are MCAs that we traditionally think of as being associated
with hematologic malignancy.
For CHIP, among those without
secondary hematologic malignancy, 6.4% had detectable
CHIP,
and 16% of those with a secondary hematologic
malignancy had detectable CHIP, corresponding to an adjusted hazards ratio of
2.8, which does also suggest increased risk,
just not quite as increased as what we saw for MCAs.
And then when we look at the specific
results from our Cox model, we are seeing two
patterns here, one similar to what we saw for MCAs.
So all of these genes have been previously associated with a
hematologic malignancy.
However, within this analysis, we did see that TP53 and
PPM1D were both associated
with cancer treatment as well.
So in summary, our findings show an increased frequency of
detectable CH among cancer survivors.
But CHIP frequency does seem to be further elevated compared to MCAs.
And although our treatment efforts are ongoing, CH frequency does
increase in cancer survivors who receive chemotherapy or radiation,
with treatment effects stronger for CHIP than for MCAs.
And it is specific events driving these associations.
To continue on with secondary hematologic malignancies, those who do
develop these cancers have higher frequencies of detectable CH as well.
But in this case, it appears to be the MCAs that have a stronger association with
secondary hematologic malignancy risk.
And thinking back to the two patterns that we analyzed, we see that
for MCAs, those MCAs associated with therapy
are different from those associated with hematologic malignancy.
But for CHIP, we did identify a few CHIP
mutations and a few CHIP genes that are associated with both therapy and
secondary hematologic malignancy risk.
So in general, we're seeing therapy-associated and some
therapy-independent effects, raising the
possibility that this accelerated biological aging of the
hematopoietic system may not just be driven by therapy, but also
possibly be a result of the physiological stress of the
cancer itself. And overall, we do feel as though examining clonal
hematopoiesis could improve risk stratification in cancer
survivors.Our treatment
analyses are currently ongoing, as I've mentioned a couple of times.
We also hope to identify potential sex-specific events and replicate these
analyses in additional cohorts.
I'd like to acknowledge all of those wonderful individuals who contributed to this
work, many of whom are in the audience right now.
I am currently a fellow at the NCI's Division of Cancer Epidemiology and
Genetics. So if you're interested in joining us, scan the QR code on the
left. And with that, I will take questions.
Feel free to, yeah, step up to a microphone.
Hey. Very cool talk. Thank you so much. I had a question.
You talk about CHIP variants and MCAs as separate
events,
but when you look at the location of the variants, are they correlated with the
MCAs, or are they truly independent?
So
it's great that you asked that question, as the prior project that I
worked on actually analyzed co-occurrence
amongst these two events. So while we don't necessarily have the sample
size to examine these co-occurrences, so of the MCAs and CHIP
within those who develop secondary hematologic malignancies, our
prior work actually does suggest that many of the CHIP
mutations seem to fall or co-occur with an
MCA, where the CHIP mutation falls within the bounds of the
co-occurring event.
Okay. Awesome. Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
So great presentation. You mentioned sex-specific effects
as a future direction. Have you considered other things like
comorbidities or ethnic background, things like that?
I think there are many possibilities that we can examine.
I think sex-specific effects are one that we're particularly
interested
in,
given the fact that our sample size is with the secondary hematologic malignancies
is quite small. So we only have about 500
individuals that we've identified so far.
And UK Biobank, thinking about other factors such as
ancestry, UK Biobank is primarily of European ancestry, so I think it's
possible to examine
other factors, but I haven't
considered much at this time.
Thank you.
Okay. I have one more question.
Yeah.
Or two.
This was with whole genome sequencing, right?
Like
30X or...
So whole exome sequencing for CHIP,
and then the MCAs were with genotyping array data.
Okay. So what was your limit of detection?
What was the minimum clone size you would need for each type of
event?
2%, around 2%.
Okay.
Or 1%.
It's not a right answer.
Okay.
Just asking.
I think the limited for the CHIP mutations, the
smallest allele fraction that we have was 2%.
And did you separate pathogenic variants from
potentially non-pathogenic variants?
So the panel that we used actually included a total of over 500
genes. So
no, but most of them were primarily leukemia driver genes.
Okay.
Okay. Thank you very much.
Okay, so I'll call up our next speaker, Dr.
Druwesh.
Good afternoon, everyone. First, I would like to thank the
organizer for giving me the opportunity to present my
work.
I don't have any disclosures.
So adenomatous colorectal polyposis is a
rare condition. It is characterized by the presence
of several polyps distributed throughout the colon and the
rectum.
The number of these polyps in the colon
determines the type of polyposis that range from
attenuated to profuse forms. Even though the
polyps are benign lesions, they may evolve into
colorectal adenocarcinoma.
The adenoma adenocarcinoma sequence is well-known,
well-established. First, alterations in APC or
cadherin beta genes are
altered and leads to an uncontrolled
proliferation. Then MAPK pathway and
TGF beta pathways are involved, and they
go further with promoting tumor growth,
and they promote adenoma polyp progression.
Then there are the loss of p53 and other
alteration that drive the transition from
high-grade dysplasia to an invasive carcinoma.
These processes are mainly
affected in sporadic cancer. However, some
hereditary colorectal syndromes can also be affected.
In fact, they are in about 10 to 12% of the cases.
And we were, in this work, more interested in the syndromes
that are associated with adenomatous polyposis, the red ones.
Despite the fact that we have
greatly advanced in the sequencing techniques and
improved the genetic counseling,
there are still a large proportion of peopleThat remain
genetically unexplained even though they have quite
suggestive
phenotype of polyposis.
There might be several reasons for that.
First, the germline pathogenic variant could be in the
known gene, but undetectable with current
technologies.
Another explanation could be that the germline variant could
affect other genes that have not been identified yet.
The polyposis could also be driven by
epigenetic modifications or multigenic factors.
Other explanation
might be because of mosaicism or
also the involvement of environmental factors that
have not been
very described yet. And in this work, we were
mostly interested in these two last points.
First, the somatic mosaicism.
It appears when a mutation occurs during embryonic
development.
The earlier the mutation occur, the
more widely is
distributed the mutation throughout the
patient's
body. And if the mutation appear
around two weeks after fertilization, then it can be absent from the
germ cells and not inherited from the parents.
If the mutation occur around or after the
third week after fertilization, they can
be absent from the blood, even if it's present in the colon.
The other major point
that we will discuss is the genotoxic microbiota
that can affect
colonic lesions. It has been shown that colonic
microbiota may contain bacteria producing the colibactin.
The colibactin is a genotoxic product
produced by some bacteria, and that
induce some
specific DNA damage that are well known as the
ones giving rise to these two cosmic molecular
signature. These signatures have been
described in normal mucosa, adenoma, and
carcinoma, especially highly prevalent in
colorectal carcinoma. And it is also known
that some of APC mutation have been
specifically associated with the colibactin
exposure.
So what we did in our study is that we
enrolled a series of 125 patients
with unexplained colorectal adenomatous polyposis.
All these patients were negative for germline
sequencing, and they didn't have any family
history.
From this series, we discarded 10 patients because of low DNA
quality.
And then for the remaining patients, we
were able to collect from one to nine different
samples, mainly neoplastic samples, but also some
normal colonic mucosa samples.
We assume that APC mosaicism could be
assessed if one
PV of APC could be detected and
shared between three independent neoplastic lesions,
or one neoplastic lesion and one normal mucosa.
Unfortunately, in this series, 55
patients were not
analyzed for APC mosaicism because we were not able to
get enough sufficient number of lesions to
assess this status.
However,
for the 60 remaining patients, we were able to
describe a mosaicism of APC in one-third
of the cases that were tested.
More generally, we found a pathogenic variant of
APC in 94% of the lesions. The
one that were wild type for APC were driven by
other oncogenes like KRAS, BRAF or beta-catenin.
And the more frequently altered
pathways in this series were like in other polyps,
RAS, WNT, and TP53
pathways.
Importantly, among the patients that we found with a
shared mosaic APC variant, we found
these variants,
retrospectively, in the blood sample for two patients.
This mutation was detected at a very low frequency.
In one of these case,
we observed a transmission of the mosaic
mutation, and the woman that was
detected for the mosaic in our cohort had three children.
Two were tested negative and one was tested positive.
He had an early diagnosis and a more
severe polyposis as compared to his mother.
Mosaicism of APC was found to be associated with
a younger age and a higher adenoma burden.
The proportion of patients that were
diagnosed early was greater in mosaic patient
as compared to non-mosaic patients, with a median age of
45 years as compared to 53 for the non-mosaic
cases.The same was observed
for adenoma burden. The proportion of patients with
a larger number of polyps was higher in mosaic
patients as compared to non-mosaic patients, with a higher number
significantly shown as here.
What we saw as well is that the pathogenic variants
that we had were
often fitting the colibactin signature that
is described in
colon cancer. And I
summarized here all
polyps for all patients. The dark boxes
are the lesions that were
presenting one motif associated with colibactin, the
white boxes, the absence of such motif.
When we looked at the whole series,
40% of the patients
had a sign of colibactin exposure
in their genome.
In parallel, we investigated whether we could find the
bacteria directly in the polyps. We tested this by
specific PCR. We show that the majority of the polyps
were--
We detected E. coli in these polyps, and we detected
the genotoxic strain in some of them, including normal
mucosa for one patient. Even though we didn't find
any strict correlation concordance
between the genomic imprinting and the presence of the
genotoxic bacteria, we were able to
see that there were a significant concordance
between the two statues.
Finally, when we looked more carefully at the clonal
architecture of the
polyposis, we found that the
colibactin-associated APC variants were subclonal
in the mosaic patients and fully clonal in the non-mosaic
patients. And we can see here two examples
showing that the blue here, APC with
the colibactin motif, were subclonal in this case and fully
clonal in here.
To conclude, what we show is that APC mosaicism may account for
one-third of unexplained cases of colorectal adenomatous
polyposis.
This suggests that mosaicism should be systematically considered
in these cases, even though the diagnostic strategy
is demanding and time-consuming.
Moreover, the infection of colibactin-producing bacteria is
highly prevalent and may act as a co-factor
mimicking the phenotype of polyposis and representing
a differential diagnosis.
And I will finish with
the acknowledgment. I thank all the collaborators that were
included in this
work. Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Come to a microscope. I mean, microscope.
My microphone. If you have questions.
One second. Oh, here we go.
Are there any online?
Thank you for your talk. If you go back a couple of slides to where you had
all your individuals listed out with presence and absence, dark and light
shaded.
Which one?
A couple more back where you had-- Yeah, exactly that one.
Yeah.
What are the rows? Is that multiple time points?
Is that genealogy?
No, these are all the polyps that we tested for each patient.
The individual polyps?
Yeah. Here are the patients, and here are all the polyps
that we got from each patient.
Why do you think it is that some polyps have it and others don't?
This is an infection, so it is not
distributed regularly all along the colon.
So some, the microbiota, is
made by a lot of different type of
bacteria, and sometimes you have
the genotoxic one and sometimes not.
I see.
Depending on the... Yeah.
So it's not a limitation by the assay to measure it, it's just-
No.
All right. Thank you.
You're
welcome.
Do you have any thoughts on what's going on in the other two-thirds of patients
where you don't see any APC germline detect?
As I said, there are multiple reasons that could
explain why we don't have this
genomic explanation. So all this kind of
might be the reason why.
I was just going to follow on from that with your list of environmental
factors, and you did look at the colibactin bacteria.
Are there other environmental exposures that could
explain some of these sporadic
phenotype cases, I guess?
I don't really know, but, what we know is that colibactin
directly impact
the fact that on pheromone
factors might be important for
proliferation and
might be there some others, but I don't know.
I just tested this one.
Mm-hmm.
Okay. Thank you.
Okay.
And our next speaker is Dr. DeWitt.
Great.
All right.
Yeah, thank you for the opportunity to speak today.
I really appreciate it, and I look forward to sharing with you all some of our
current and recent work surrounding the impact of patient biology
on racial disparities in breast cancer outcome.
This work is actually currently pre-printed on BioRxiv, and
we're finishing up the revisions for it right now.
I do not have any disclosures.
So racial disparities in cancer outcome is a pretty pervasive
clinical challenge across most tumor types, as depicted here,
where we're looking at five-year survival rates across different tumor types for
Black and white cancer patients. And what we can see is that the
majority of tumor types have,
in bold, a observable cancer disparity
in terms of outcome.
And investigations into the underlying mechanisms
to explain these disparities typically surround two
main avenues. One being the patient intrinsic factors,
those relating to germline genetics associated with ancestry,
but also the patient extrinsic factors like more social or
structural determinants of health.
But current gaps exist. One of them being pretty severe
under-representation in most patient tumor data sets,
insufficient patient annotations or inconsistent clinical
annotations,
a overall lack of representative model systems for basic
R&D work, and unfortunately,
there's a lot of field siloing, which is a
problem. But if we zoom in on breast cancer and utilize
breast cancer as a case study to look at cancer
disparities, what we'll find is breast cancer is the
most common cancer diagnosis for women and the second most deadly.
And it turns out that Black women are consistently 40% more likely to die
from a breast cancer diagnosis compared to white women.
And this has been true for a
long time actually, even despite targeted therapeutic
advancements like endocrine therapy.
And it's actually also true for all different
subtypes of breast cancer, regardless of hormone receptor
or HER2 status. Black women have worse outcome.
So the question is why? Why are Black women more likely to die from a breast
cancer diagnosis? And the hypothesis that we have driving
this work is that both the intrinsic ancestral
related elements are impacting the somatic molecular
biology, of course. But in addition to that, we have these social and
structural drivers that are working in an overlapping fashion
altogether to impact the underlying molecular biology and
ultimately impact the inequities we see in
cancer survival.
So to get at addressing this big question, we started out by
forming a partnership with the VA, where we obtained a breast tumor
data set of about 60 archival HR
positive breast tumors.
And we oversampled for Black women.
And this is a pretty unique data set because we were able to control in it,
we're able to control for the healthcare system access.
We have pretty good patient annotations, including
the clinical pathologicals and additionally, socioeconomic indicators like
poverty burden, which I'll be talking about,
in addition to the actual tumor tissue samples themselves.
And when we did bulk RNA sequencing from these tumors and identified pathway
groupings, what we found are signatures surrounding the
extracellular matrix, in particular collagen, and the immune
system to be significantly differently regulated in tumors from Black women.
And we thought that this was pretty interesting because we know from literature
that the normal breast environment, or collagen within the normal breast
environment, can vary across different races and ethnicities.
So we wanted to explore this a bit deeper in the tumors, and what we did
is we
stained for collagen using trichrome, so depicted here in blue is the collagen.
And we found that the tumors from Black women were in fact enriched
for tumoral collagen, consistent with prior reports in triple
negative.
And when we try to back translate this into the lab to hopefully
develop some, or identify some model systems that we can utilize
for in vitro work, we assembled a panel of breast
tumor cell lines, all HR positive from Black or white patients.
And we wanted to first grow these cells in
three dimensions, so spheroid assays.
And we started out with the standard soft agar approach as their
matrix. And the cell lines from Black women failed to
thrive at all.
But when we switched that matrix to a collagen-containing Matrigel,
we were able to achieve robust growth, suggesting that there's some
fundamental requirements and differences that these cell lines
need in order to be truly utilized in the lab
setting. And this also compares to the bread and butter cell lines
for breast cancer, the MCF7 and T47D cells, which grow
optimally regardless.
Now, when we translate this into mice and use
xenografting experiments, this kind of gets at
the question of, is it possible for this in a tumor
collagen phenotype to be somewhat tumor cell intrinsic?
And when we grow these cells in mice, what we found is that the tumors
from, or the HCC1500 tumor cells, were able to intrinsically
promote an increase in this tumoral collagen
deposition, similar to what we saw in
patients.And we had 100% take
rate for these palpable tumors, but the MDA-175 cells
failed to generate palpable tumors.
They formed really weird, squishy, sub-palpable tumors
that were just fundamentally different than to the rest.
But when we look at the actual collagen orientation in the way that these
fibers are structured in the tumors themselves, for the patients, what
we found is an increase in these radially aligned
collagen fibers relative to the tumor cells, so in
the Black patients. And this is thought to be more of a
tumor-permissive architecture for the collagen fiber
alignment. And that was really strikingly mirrored by the
HCC1500 cells grown in mice. And those were the
cells that formed really strong palpable tumors.
But the MDA cells, which failed to do so, did not have this
radial alignment that we see here.
So this phenotype really hints at an underlying
metastatic
difference or possibility. So we wanted to explore that a little
further, and we compiled some
simulations of tumor cell invasion potential based on the RNA
sequencing data from the patients.
And when we modulate different collagen densities and then predict
what happens to the tumor cells themselves in terms of their invasion potential,
what we find is that only for Black patients, as we increase
collagen density, do we see an increase in that invasion potential,
which we do not see for the tumor cells from white women.
We see the opposite effect.
And when we further account for a change in
increase in collagen alignment in the high-density collagen
simulations mimicking what is happening in a
collagen-dense tumor, we see only for tumor cells from
Black women, when we have aligned collagen, do we see a further increase in that
invasion potential,
whereas the
dense collagen, regardless of if it's aligned or not, for white women, is
tumor
cell inhibiting.
So for the last part of my talk, I want to switch back to the immune
system pathway that came out of our pathway grouping.
And we think that this is also an important element here because
we know that the ECM, in particular collagen, can be immunomodulatory.
So we wanted to dive into this a bit further, and we started out by just
doing CIBERSORT deconvolution of our tumor cells or
of the
patient RNA sequencing, and just to look at major
immune populations. And if we focus on the T cells,
the CD4, CD8 T cells in red and purple, I know the blue is
pretty distracting, but we'll focus on the red and the purple for right now.
The CD8 T cells are enriched in tumors from white women, and the
CD4 T cells are enriched in tumors from Black women.
And that increase in CD4 T cell ratios is a prognostically
unfavorable phenotype. And we had access
to a collaborative
data set through the Carolina Breast Cancer Study from our collaborators,
and when we ran the same analyses, we saw the same effect.
And this is not new.
Other people have shown this as well, that the tumors from Black women are
predicted to have a more immunosuppressive T cell
landscape.
But we wanted to look through an additional layer to see, is it possible
for extrinsic factors like poverty burden to further associate with some of these
differences? And the reason why this is an important thing to consider is because
in the United States, for example, Black women are much more likely to live in
poverty, and we know that chronic stress is
immunomodulatory. So if poverty burden were to affect the molecular
biology of the tumor, then Black women would be at increased risk.
And when we do that and we stratify patients by poverty burden and consider high
poverty burden patients, what we see is a further increase in that
CD4 prognostically unfavorable T cell signature.
And this is also validated with our collaborator, Melissa
Troester's group,
with the Carolina Breast Cancer Study, where we see, again, a further increase in
the ratio of that CD4 to CD8 T cell.
And what's interesting with this data set is we were powered enough to also
look at white women of high poverty burden, and we see a similar phenotype.
So we really think that poverty burden is a
race-agnostic indicator of poor T cell
landscapes, and that maybe disproportionately affect
Black women.
And I'll end with the working model for our paper,
which we dive into a little bit more of the molecular underpinnings surrounding a
candidate called STAT4. I encourage you all to check it out.
But the takeaway I want to leave you with is that we believe that
their patient extrinsic and intrinsic factors are intricately
entwined in modulating and affecting the tumoral biology.
And in order to make the next steps in achieving cancer health
equity and closing those gaps,
I think we need to bring more representative model systems
and encourage a multitude of factors
in our clinical data sets as well, so that when we go back and we try mining these
data, we can have better representation of the actual factors
affecting a patient's biology.
And with that, I'll thank my mentor, Swasti,
the rest of my lab, and our many collaborators. It's been a team effort.
And I'd like to point out Dr. Karabaich, who helped with the migration and invasion
predictions, is giving a poster today.
And my boss wanted me to say that we are accepting a new postdoc.
If you're interested and have some cancer immunology backgrounds, we'd love
to chat. Thanks.
Hi. Kara Maxwell from Penn. I'm sorry if you mentioned this and I missed it.
What was the hormone receptor status in your VA cohort
between the Black and the white women?
And then the models you used are all ER-positive luminal models.
Do you think that that has any effect?
Yeah. The VA data set, they're all HR positive.
Most are ER positive, but I think there were a couple that were
PR positive and not ER. But yeah, HR positive, all of them.
And then the second question was, do I think that the hormone receptor-
Yeah. Do you think that your phenotype is going to hold over to triple-negative
since-
Oh, yeah
... women tend to get more triple-negative breast cancer.
Yeah.
I see.
So
for the immune, I do think so.
And particularly for the collagen phenotypes, there's been work from
Heather Dunn's group that actually showed, which I ran into last year,
and they had almost identical results for triple-negative.
So, I do think it holds through. Yeah.
Hi, I'm Lucas Mavromatis from NYU.
I was just curious about the graph you showed right at the beginning of the
presentation on mortality rates by race
over the decades. And actually,
it seemed like there was a couple
decades there where the mortality rates were similar.
And so I wondered like-
The beginning?
Yeah.
I wonder what you think about that.
Well, so my understanding is initially, before we had
therapies for breast cancer, a breast cancer diagnosis was
essentially
really difficult to treat and kind of a death sentence.
So I think it wasn't until endocrine therapy
or some forms of hormone therapy hit the market that we truly started
seeing,
because most of breast cancer is hormone regulated, is when we started to see the
survival take off, yeah.
Thanks.
Great presentation. Just a quick question about single
nucleotide polymorphisms in the genes of interest.
Are there any stratifying SNPs that allow you to separate these
populations-
Oh, yeah
... that can predict the collagen as well as the immune infiltration?
Yeah. So we did whole exome sequencing to
get at that exact point. The quality was
not very good from the section, so we
had a really hard time identifying the SNPs.
We were able to
make ancestry calls, but we weren't
super confident in much more than that.
So that is something we're interested in following up on, yeah.
Great presentation. So from a breast oncologist, a quick question.
Have you looked at within the Black women,
young versus old age? There's some work that we have
done in collaboration with investigators in India, where we found
that in young onset breast cancer,
the extracellular matrix and the collagen genes are really
implicated in the disease biology and account for the aggressiveness compared
to the old onset. And young onset, we defined it as less than 40.
So I'm really curious if you plan to do age match
controls between Black and white women.
Yeah, that's a really good question.
If you are
a Black woman, you are more likely to be diagnosed with
premenopausal breast cancer in general.
So I wonder how that contributes to what you see there.
In our data set, it's actually kind of an interesting data set because,
I think on average, the median age was two years higher for the Black
women in our cohort. So they were, on average, slightly
older. Other than that, there
was no statistical difference between the two.
So we do think that they're pretty well age matched.
But if you look at
the nuances of menopausal, perimenopausal, there are some subtle differences.
But I haven't
delved into that yet.
Okay, last question.
Hi. Very cool talk. I'm curious, you talked about the kind of
squishy tumor when-
Yeah
... you were putting it into the mouse.
And so is the
collagen structure, is that coming from the tumor cells themselves, or is it
modulating the microenvironment and changing the
cancer-associated fibroblasts?
Yeah. So I don't know. I think it could be doing both.
I know it's an intrinsic phenotype.
Whether it's direct that they can do it themselves, there are
some metalloprotease differences in them, but I
imagine that there's some type of crosstalk happening with the fibroblasts for
sure. But I don't know for certain.
Thank you.
Okay, and I'll invite our next speaker, Dr.
Abubakar.
Okay. Thank you very much
to the organizers for the invitation and for the opportunity
to present our work investigating the
presence of microdysplastic signatures in normal breast
tissues and how this can inform
subsequent cancer risk and etiologic origins.
I have no disclosures.
The premise of this work, essentially, is that malignant transformation
involves progressive changes in cellular morphology,
beginning from normal tissue to intraductal
hyperplasia, atypical intraductal hyperplasia,
ductal carcinoma in situ, and ultimately
infiltrating ductal carcinoma.
Specifically, the transition from normal cell
to a cancer cell is characterized by specific cellular
changes, and these include changes in nuclear size,
nuclear shape, nuclear chromasia, and nuclear
counts.However,
the point along the early carcinogenesis trajectory
when these changes first signal cancer risk
and etiologic origins remain unknown.
If you
think about current approaches for histologic risk
prediction in premalignant tissue,
these are typically based on human visual
interpretation of dysplastic changes in epithelial cells.
But we must remember that human visual histologic thresholds may not
necessarily align with early biological risk of
cancer. So to give an example, more than
90% of the 1.2 million benign breast biopsies that are
performed in the United States annually do not show
visually evident dysplastic changes.
And in absolute terms, most breast cancers are going to
arise among women who do not show dysplasia.
So why is that?
So to address this question, this gap, we asked a
simple question, but the answer has profound implications.
So we simply asked, are there some visual changes in
normal breast tissues that can inform subsequent cancer risk and
etiology?
So to address this question, we turned to a really
unique
epidemiologic
cohort. So that is the Corman Tissue Bank.
So this is a cohort, a US-based cohort of healthy women who
donated their normal breast tissues.
These were women between 18 to 75 years of age, and
these have now been followed up for cancer development with a median
follow-up of six years and a range of one to 16
years. The current analysis comprised about
3,415 women who donated their tissues between
2009 to 2016, and of these,
104 have developed breast cancer.
And for these women, we also have questionnaire-based data on risk factors,
as well as digitized histologic sections of
H&Es at the time that they donated their normal breast tissues.
So to characterize cytomorphologic
changes in the tissues, we developed a single-cell pathology
pipeline. So essentially, this began by the
development of a tissue segmentation algorithm, which allowed
us to partition the normal tissue into the epithelial and
stromal regions. And then subsequently, we developed two
cell level algorithms,
one for epithelial cell segmentation and the other for
stromal cell detection. So by linking these two cell
level algorithms to the tissue segmentation algorithm, we were able
to perform compartment-specific single-cell
analysis, so restricted to the epithelial and stromal compartments.
So based on this, we're able to generate quantitative data across
54 million epithelial and 18 million stromal cells.
And the features that we derived essentially were features of nuclear
size, so that is nuclear area and epithelial nuclear perimeter.
We're also able to derive
information on epithelial nuclear chromasia, that is intensity of staining
of the epithelial nuclei, and then also information about
epithelial nuclear density, which says something about hyperplasia,
nuclear contour irregularity, which tells us something about nuclear pleomorphism
or nuclear shape, and then stromal cell density, which tells
us about
small drain inflammation in the tissue.
So, based on these metrics, by using epithelial nuclear
area perimeter and stromal cell density, we defined
what we refer to as biologically informed microdysplastic signatures.
So essentially, four signatures were defined.
The absent signature is where we do not have evidence of
epithelial nuclear megaly and evidence of stromal inflammation in the tissue.
Then there is the epithelial signature, which essentially is
evidence of epithelial nuclear megaly, but no evidence of stromal
inflammation. Then we have the stromal signature, which is
where there isn't evidence of epithelial nuclear megaly, but there
is evidence of stromal inflammation, and the mixed
epithelial and stromal, where we have both epithelial nuclear megaly
as well as evidence of stromal
inflammation. So this slide essentially
shows a cytomorphologic portrait of the different
microdysplastic signatures. The epithelial signature
essentially is characterized by high nuclear area, high nuclear
perimeter, and high nuclear chromasia, while the stromal
signature was defined by high stromal cell density, high nuclear
contour irregularity, and high epithelial nuclear density.
The mixed signature shares similar profile as the epithelial signature,
but the important distinction here is that the mixed signature
also has high stromal cell density, suggesting
the superimposition of inflammation.
So
for a subset of patients, when we linked the H&E-based
signatures with
bulk RNA-Seq, we observed about
356 genes to be differentially expressed between
women who had a stromal signature and those who didn't.
And gene set enrichment and gene-gene interaction networks showed
this signature to be characterized by immune response and
inflammatory signaling, whereas the mixed
signature was essentially characterized by wound repair
programs.So when we looked at these
microdysplastic signatures
with respect to breast cancer incidence, we found women
who had any microdysplastic signature in their normal breast tissue to have a
higher risk of developing breast cancer in the future.
And when we adjusted for known breast cancer risk factors
in multivariable Cox proportional hazards regression models, we found the
presence of any microdysplastic signature in normal breast tissue to be associated
with a more than twofold increased
risk of developing subsequent breast cancer.
And when we looked at the individual microdysplastic signatures, what we
found among all women was having either the epithelial, stromal,
or mixed microdysplastic signature was associated with at least
twofold increased risk of developing breast cancer in the future,
and this was irrespective of age. So we saw this
among women who were less than 50 years of age, and those
who were more than 50 years of age at the time of their normal breast tissue
donation. So to validate our findings and
also test its clinical relevance among
individuals who have been biopsied for some sort of
clinical indication but were then given a histological
diagnosis of non-proliferative disease without atypia,
we tested these microdysplastic signatures in those patients.
And what we found, essentially, was that the presence of either the
epithelial, stromal, or mixed microdysplastic signature was
associated with subsequent breast cancer risk overall,
and also irrespective of age. So we saw this among women who
had a benign breast disease diagnosis at less than 50 and those who were
diagnosed at more than 50 years of age.
So next, we tried to rule out the possibility that the
microdysplastic signatures that we were picking probably
represented ongoing disease at the time those biopsies were taken.
So we modeled this for women who developed breast cancer
five years post donation of histologically normal
breast tissue. And what we found here was an almost threefold increased
risk of subsequent cancer development for a woman
with any microdysplastic signature.
And if we look at the individual signatures, we saw an almost
fourfold increased risk for women with a stromal
signature.
So next, we try to see if these signatures are predictive of the particular
subtype of breast cancer that a woman is going to develop
within the context of the tissue phenotype.
So we made three important observations here.
The first one being that the stromal signature, which I've showed you to be the
inflammatory signature, was associated with
ER-negative breast cancer irrespective of the tissue
context. But the risk was strongest in the
stroma-rich tissues. So those are tissues with a high extracellular
matrix, suggesting that the presence of inflammation in the context of
high extracellular matrix
is synergistically associated with increased risk of aggressive
ER-negative breast cancers. Next, we made a context-dependent
observation of a relationship between the
epithelial signature and risk of
ER-negative and ER-positive breast cancer, such that among women with
stroma-rich tissue, the epithelial signature was more strongly
associated with ER-negative breast cancer, whereas among those with
adipose-rich tissue, it was more strongly associated
with ER-positive breast cancer. The mixed signature was associated with
both subtypes. So lastly, we
wanted to understand what are the
epidemiologic risk factors that relate to these
signatures in normal tissue. And our findings essentially
suggest that risk factors for aggressive breast cancer, including younger age,
black race, multiparity, positive family history of breast
cancer, were strongly associated with
the stromal signature, suggesting that
the stromal pathway might be the
histogenesis by which these risk factors impact
aggressive breast cancer risk. Whereas the mixed signature was
defined by obesity and older age at first
child birth. So in conclusion, our findings suggest that
oncogenic processes may imprint occult phenotypic
changes in breast tissues long before cancer
diagnosis. And this could have implications for breast
cancer risk prediction, targeted prevention, as
well as early interception strategies.
But further work is clearly warranted to characterize these
microdysplastic signatures as biomarkers of risk and early
interception. So I'll end by acknowledging my colleagues
at the NCI DCEG, as well as
collaborators from the Susan G. Komen Tissue Bank and others for
their contribution to this study.
So thank you so much, and I'm happy to take questions.
Okay. We have time for a couple questions.
I was going to start with a question if it's okay.
Did you have information on breast density
for these women?
Not for these women.
However, so one of our colleagues
has been working quite
assiduously to try to get mammographic density information for
these women. So in the next set of analysis, we want to be able to
integrate mammographic density with these
microdysplastic signatures to see what we find.
Mm-hmm.
Hey, Dr. Chiwuka from Freedom. I'm curious how you think about
the fact that you have a tissue sample from one side of the breast and presumably
the cancer initiates in some other side.
Are you thinking that the microdisplastic signature is present throughout the whole
tissue? Do you have multiple samples to assess this? How do you think about that?
Yeah, thank you. So that's a great question.
I didn't show that here, but we've
thought about that, and then we try to address it.
So, and it's in our paper. So what we did essentially is for some of these
women,
we know the site of the breast cancer, and we know the site where the
biopsy was taken. So we could define if it's ipsilateral, same
side, or contralateral, different sides.
And we kind of run the analysis both in healthy women and in benign breast disease
to see, is this mostly an ipsilateral phenomena or is it
contralateral or both? So but what I can tell you is that
it's both. So we see that the presence of a microdisplastic signature,
irrespective of whatever breast it is taken, is associated with
subsequent breast cancer risk. But what we think is that
these signatures may tell us something about global exposure to
risk factors.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Okay, and our next presentation is Dr. Advani.
Thank you so much.
Good afternoon, everybody. On behalf of my co-investigators, it is an honor,
and I'm really grateful to present our work today on deep plasma proteomics for
early-stage breast cancer detection.
These are some of my financial disclosures.
So first, let's start with defining the problem, which is essentially reduced
sensitivity for detection of breast cancer in women with dense breast
tissue on routine screening mammogram.
So what is dense breast tissue? It refers to a higher proportion of
fibroglandular tissue relative to fatty tissue in
mammogram. The American College of Radiology uses the BI-RADS
classification system to grade breast density,
ranging from Grade A, which is almost entirely fatty tissue,
to Grade D, which is extremely dense breast tissue.
And we know that 50% of women in the United States above the age of 40
years have category C and D breast density.
So why does breast density matter? For two important reasons.
One, it is an increased risk factor for breast cancer.
And number two, as I mentioned, it reduces the sensitivity for detection of
breast cancer in women with dense breast tissue, and they get diagnosed with
a higher incidence of interval cancers and also cancers at later
stages.
Further recent updates to mammography regulations requiring
stricter reporting of density reflects an increasing focus
on personalizing and refining strategies for screening in the specific
patient population.
So we know that the use of supplemental breast imaging, such as breast MRI,
contrast enhanced mammography, and whole breast ultrasound, is well
established in women that are at increased risk of developing breast cancer
during their lifetime. But there is no clear consensus on the
use of these supplemental breast imaging modalities in women that have dense
breast tissue who otherwise do not have high-risk criteria.
And we can see here across the board that breast imaging has
performed with different characteristics.
For example, breast MRI has a high sensitivity but a
relatively lower specificity, which translates into a higher
recall rate as well as false positive rate.
Breast MRIs are also associated with really high costs and inconsistent
insurance coverage, patient anxiety, claustrophobia,
and lack of equitable access. Contrast enhanced mammography has
sensitivities that are approaching that of the MRI, but they are
involving contrast administration and also are not widely accessible.
Whole breast ultrasound is widely accessible, but you can see its
sensitivity is very low and it's operator dependent.
So that brings me to the first unmet need, which is a simple,
cost-effective, readily available sensitive test for women
with dense breast tissue.
Further, we also know that liquid biopsy-based tests that are now currently
available have transformed the early cancer detection landscape.
The currently available tests are essentially based on methylation of
cell-free DNA or detection of cell-free DNA and protein
fragments in the plasma. And you can see here that
tests that are currently available are essentially for detecting multiple
cancers. And while they have excellent specificity,
they unfortunately have really low sensitivity for diagnosis of
breast cancer at earlier stages, like stage one and stage two.
And this is not surprising because early-stage breast cancers do have a
lower shedding rate of cell-free DNA, and this is particularly true for
early-stage cancers like breast and prostate.
So this brings me to the second unmet need.
That is a sensitive test that can find cancers early.
And as a practicing clinician, I cannot emphasize enough how important it
is for these cancers to be detected early when they're still curable.
And we believe that the answers to these unmet needs lies in deep
proteomics. So deep proteomics has the ability to
analyze several thousands of proteins across a wide
range with increased sensitivity.
So briefly going over some of this methodology.
So essentially with plasma preparation, approximately 100 microliters of plasma
are processed through a magnetic bead-based enrichment step to enrich the
proteins of interest. And then the enriched proteins are then digested
using trypsin to generate peptides, which are then washed and then
analyzed over the mass spectrometer.
These identified peptides are then mapped back to proteins,
normalized, and then analyzed using a machine-based
classifier to differentiate cancer individuals from those that
are healthy.And essentially here, the plate
layout demonstrates that 76 samples can be processed simultaneously
with appropriate positive and negative controls.
And here you can see that the number of protein IDs is similar
between the cancer groups that is highlighted in blue and the
healthy individuals that are highlighted in green.
And this red curve here demonstrates that the technology has the
capacity to detect 9,000 proteins
across several orders of magnitude, thereby
establishing the deep proteomic platform for early cancer
detection.
So how does this translate clinically?
In a case-control study that included 335 women,
219 of which were healthy and 116 were breast cancer patients
with early-stage breast cancer, stage zero to stage two.
The breast density information was available on 70% of these
patients. The median number of proteins that were identified
across breast cancer and healthy controls were about 7,000
each.
In this particular study, we demonstrate that the machine learning classifier
that was trained and validated performed well with an area under the curve of
0.96, a sensitivity of
86.2%, and a specificity of
90.4%. And when we focus on the group of patients that
had high breast density, we see that the sensitivity is
90.2% with a fixed specificity of
90.4%. It is important to acknowledge that the number of patients is
relatively low in the high breast density group.
In an early study of 1,250 women from two large biobank
cohorts, the individuals were matched between healthy and
cancer for age, BMI, and the source of the biobanked
samples. And in the training set, about 845 patients
were included. In the validation set, that was a held-out validation set,
397 patients were included. And
here you can see that the validation set performed really well with an area under
the curve of 0.975 and sensitivity and specificity
each of 92%. But what's really important to
focus on is the unmet need. So here the sensitivity of this
assay in detecting stage zero patients was about
84.6%, stage one 88%, and
stage two close to 97%. More importantly,
high sensitivity was demonstrated across multiple clinically relevant
molecular subtypes. For example, hormone receptor-positive, HER2
negative, and triple-negative groups.
This was also demonstrated across pathologic subtypes such as
invasive ductal carcinoma, which we know is the most common histologic
subtype of breast cancer, and invasive lobular carcinoma, the much
rarer but more sneaky subtype in mammograms.
Again, important to acknowledge that the number of patients in each group is
relatively small and requires validation in larger groups.
Breast density was not analyzed in this analysis due to lack of
information being available from the biobanked samples.
I would also like to highlight some early interim findings from an ongoing
prospective trial of approximately 300 women recruited
just prior to a diagnostic mammogram from over 10
unique sites spread out geographically.
This assay demonstrated a sensitivity of 89%, more
importantly, a negative predictive value of 93%.
When we see the small group of women, 29 patients that had dense breast
tissue, this assay had an 80% sensitivity for detection
of early-stage breast cancer. And in a smaller group of
21 patients, 91% sensitivity is demonstrated in
women with dense breast tissue and high risk based on the Gail
model.
There are several prospective trials that are currently underway, including at Mayo
Clinic, in order to validate the promising results that I have just shown.
Additionally, future studies are being designed to focus our validation
specifically in women of interest, which is dense breast
tissue. So in summary, addressing unmet
need one, this liquid biopsy-based assay on deep
proteomics is intended to supplement routine screening
mammography, but offering a sensitive,
specific, cost-effective, and widely available
test for women with dense breast tissue compared to routinely
available supplemental imaging such as MRI.
But it helps us to identify accurately those subgroup of
women that will benefit most from supplemental screening
strategies such as MRI, and it has the potential to
optimize the use of supplemental imaging while
simultaneously addressing unmet need two, which is
detecting breast cancers at an early stage and thereby
improving the long-term oncologic outcomes of breast cancer.
So with that, I would like to thank you for your attention and a very special thank
you to the women and the families that participated in the clinical studies, and
a special shout-out to the team at Astron for their dedication,
commitment to eradicating breast cancer. Thank you so much.
Great talk. Thank you. Do you see any differences
across race or ethnicity? Because I noticed that in the training set,
it was like 2% were Black, right? Is that
right?
Yeah. So I think in different studies there was a different distribution, but
unfortunately, in some of the cohorts, it was 80%
or more of patients were Caucasian, and that's one of the focuses in the
prospective trials is to make sure that we have equitable
distribution of race and ethnic groups.
But in one of the analyses, we did not see a difference in the classifier based on
race.
Okay. Because I'm just wondering,
I know that the stats are probably really difficult with such low numbers,
but I'm wondering if you were to look at the ones who didn't
align, were they more often non-white?
We haven't specifically looked at it just because of the smaller numbers, but happy
to go back and look at that specifically.
But we want to make sure that we're enriching for patients that are
of non-Caucasian race as well as non-Hispanic ethnicity to be able to answer
that more specifically.
Yeah.
Cool.
Hi. Very interesting talk. I was wondering what sort of
workup the patients
underwent who tested negative on the proteomic assay,
in order to calculate sensitivity and how that compares to the workup that the
patients
underwent who tested negative for mammography or
MRI. Was the sort of ground truth ascertained in the same way in
making that comparison?
Yeah. So I think a lot of those questions will be answered in the carefully
designed prospective studies, right, to see how the downstream workup goes, because
that's important as well. I think, the training and the validation
set was predominantly obtained from biobank samples.
We really don't have that kind of information available.
But these are all questions including downstream costs of evaluation that we plan
to answer in the prospective trials.
Hi. A really interesting talk. Caitlin White from NCI.
I was actually wondering, could this method actually be
seen as a potential mechanism for early detection among
ER-negative tumors?
Yes. So as I mentioned, we're hoping that this assay can be used
agnostic of molecular subtypes, and thus far, we have seen that
signal
in the biobank samples. But,
of course, it's too early to consider that without
prospective data. But so far, the data looks very compelling that
agnostic of the subtype, either by ductal or
lobular and also by molecular subtype.
We do expect this to be a test for all.
And then just a super quick follow-up question.
Yeah.
Based off of the 80% detection rate that you found for
the early stage one and stage two tumors, was there any
difference between the molecular subtype?
Was there any disparities for that missingness?
I don't think we've specifically looked at that, but happy to look at it.
Okay, no problem. Thank you.
Thank you.
Hi, just a really quick question. So how was density assessed?
Was it subjective, objective? How's that measured?
Because it can be quite subjective when radiologists assign BI-RADS.
Yeah. So we essentially did depend upon the information that was provided
on the mammogram reports.
But that's sort of what the information that we had is based on whatever was
provided.
Thank you.
Wasn't verified.
Last one, really quickly. So there are some data emerging on the
landscape of proteomics from breast cancer, specifically from triple negative.
Have you tried to match what you find in your signature from the tissue level to
see if there's a match in the proteins if they make sense?
No, we haven't done this matching with tissue.
Thank you.
Here
we go. And our next speaker is Ms. Anna
Pagada.
Hi, everyone. My name is Akshaya Annapragada.
I am an MD-PhD student at Johns Hopkins, and I'm very excited to talk with you
today about our work developing non-invasive diagnostic tests for
both non-cancerous liver diseases as well as liver cancer.
I'm required to make the following disclosures.
So unlike many cancers, the incidence in mortality from hepatocellular
carcinoma has been increasing over the last two decades.
And one of the reasons for this is large global unscreened populations.
So among those at high risk for liver cancer with viral hepatitis or
cirrhosis, there are screening guidelines calling for biannual
ultrasound and alpha-fetoprotein.
But unfortunately, less than 20% of individuals receive
guideline-adherent screening.
There's also a large and growing group of individuals in the US, maybe
as many as one in four, who have metabolic-associated liver
disease and are at high risk but currently receive no screening.
So for all of these reasons, there's great interest in high-performance,
sensitive, accessible blood-based diagnostics for liver cancer.
And as a group, one of the ways that we've been thinking about this is through this
idea of the cell-free DNA fragmentome, or the full compendium
of tens of millions of cell-free DNA fragments that are found freely
in the circulation after they're released from dying cells.
And our observation has been that the genome-wide size and distribution of these
fragments really reflects underlying genomic, epigenomic,
and chromatin state changes that occur in cells from which these fragments
originate. And one of the benefits of fragmentomic
analyses are that unlike targeted sequencing that looks at
specific genes or specific mutations, when you look at the fragmentome,
you can look genome-wide at millions of possible nuanced
alterations that can then be assayed from inexpensive,
accessible, low coverage, whole genome sequencing.
So we've built many different computational approaches to look at the
fragmentome from this type of accessible sequencing data.
And today, I'll talk about two of these, DELPHI and ARTEMIS.
So DELPHI, or DNA Evaluation of Fragments for Early Interception,
is based on this observation that cell-free DNA fragment lengths in the
circulation in healthy individuals are very tightly controlled
around 167 base pairs, reflecting the length of a
fragment wrapped around a nucleosome in the bloodstream.
And then you get cut points in between nucleosomes.
But as the structure becomes dysregulated and changed in cancer,
you get very aberrant fragmentation
profiles.ARTEMIS, or Analysis of Repeat
Elements in Disease, is a complementary approach that looks
at the so-called dark genome of lines, signs, transposable
elements, satellites, and other repeat elements that have
historically been excluded from analyses because of challenges in their
alignment.
And ARTEMIS looks at 1.2 billion k-mers, or short DNA
sequences, in a completely alignment-free fashion that can
then be used to construct a global repeat landscape from short read
sequencing data.
And by using both DELPHI fragmentation profiles and ARTEMIS repeat
landscapes in machine learning approaches, we can develop
high-performance tests to detect cancer.
So we began by looking genome-wide at fragmentation profiles
in five megabase bins on every chromosomal arm.
And looking at the ratio of short to long fragments, we see that these
are highly consistent in individuals without liver disease, and then
start to become very aberrant and chaotic in individuals with liver cancer.
So we used these fragmentation profiles to train a machine learning
model in both a screening setting of healthy individuals
and a surveillance setting of high-risk individuals and
found that across all stages of liver cancer, we were able to detect
these tumors with high sensitivity and specificity.
And this locked model, when applied to an external validation
cohort of individual sequence at a separate institution,
really maintained this performance.
So this was an exciting demonstration of the ability to detect liver cancer in the
blood. But as we looked at this, one of the things we became interested in
was the fact that while these alterations were most dramatic in hepatocellular
carcinoma, we could see subtle patterns of change
even in diseases like cirrhosis that may eventually lead to liver cancer.
So we know that liver disease exists on a continuum, from
early injury to fibrosis, cirrhosis, and eventually hepatocellular
carcinoma.
And in its early stages, there are treatments that can reverse fibrosis.
And even among individuals with cirrhosis, we know that timely
identification can enable improved disease management, as well
as the initiation of effective HCC surveillance.
But unfortunately, finding these individuals is really
challenging, especially prior to decompensated liver
failure. So we designed a study to look at this
in separate discovery and validation cohorts comprising
individuals with healthy livers, individuals with early
fibrosis and steatosis, and individuals with advanced
fibrosis and cirrhosis. And excitingly, our publication on this just
came out a few weeks ago.
So when we first looked just at fragment lengths, we saw that they were
shorter in individuals with cirrhosis.
And then looking genome-wide at fragmentation profiles,
repeat landscapes, and fragment distributions at
epigenetic hotspots, there were patterns of aberration that were
evident in these non-cancerous liver diseases, in
contrast to the relatively consistent and homogenous patterns of
both fragmentation and repeat element changes that were seen in healthy
individuals.
So we went on to train an ARTEMIS and DELPHI model for the detection of
fibrotic liver disease, and found that in our cross-validated cohort,
we detected both early liver disease and advanced fibrosis and
cirrhosis with high performance.
And in a locked validation, we detected about 50% of
individuals with early liver disease and about 80% of
individuals with advanced fibrosis and cirrhosis.
And one of the things that was exciting about this is that this potentially
presented a pretty substantial improvement over a commonly used
clinical biomarker, FIB-4, the fibrosis-4 index, that
looks at liver enzymes, platelets, and age.
So it's possible that fragmentomic analyses really have a complementary
role to play in enhancing this type of detection.
But historically, cell-free DNA liquid biopsies have really been used for cancer.
So we were wondering what kind of signal are we picking up on in these
non-cancerous chronic diseases.
So we performed whole methylome sequencing on a subset of the cohort and
then performed a cell type deconvolution.
And what we saw is that contributions to the fragmentome were
altered in individuals with cirrhosis, both from immune cells
as well as liver-specific cells.
And interestingly, when we looked at fragments with a unique methylation signature
pointing to one of these altered cell types, we saw that the
unmethylated fragments in cirrhosis tended to be shorter,
and that these unique methylation sites then mapped
to regions of the genome that were overall enriched for short fragments in
cirrhosis. So this kind of points to the potential biological
origins of that fragment size shift that we initially saw in
cirrhosis.
So now knowing that there is a liver-specific signal we can pick up on, we
evaluated cross-reactivity of the locked model in other fibrotic
origin conditions like chronic pancreatitis and benign lung
nodules, as well as inflammatory conditions.
And we saw that scores remained low, indicating that there was a
liver-specific signal. And when we evaluated
along the x-axis here, this fibrosis and cirrhosis
model in liver cancer, we saw that scores were elevated,
reflecting the fibrotic origins of many liver cancers.
But in contrast, along the y-axis, you can see the liver cancer model I talked
about really only has elevated scores in liver
malignancy.
So clearly, this type of fragmentomic approach can pick up on both
a liver disease-specific signal as well as a liver cancer-specific
signal.And this opens the door to an exciting
possibility that we have this Artemis/Delphi blood
test to pick up on fibrotic and cirrhotic liver disease,
which we can then use to initiate effective disease management for patients
and route them to liver cancer surveillance.
And in that setting, we also have a blood test for the detection of liver
cancer.
So we're quite excited about this initial demonstration that fragmentation
profiles and repeat landscapes
are altered not only in liver cancer, but in these high-risk liver
diseases that can go on to progress to liver cancer.
And that we can adapt the Artemis and Delphi approaches for detection of
pre-cancer and chronic non-malignant conditions.
So there are efforts underway in the lab to translate this approach in diverse
clinical settings, both for early detection of cancer and for
other high-risk non-cancer conditions.
And I'll end by thanking the cancer genomics lab, in particular my advisors,
Victor Velculescu and Rob Scharf, Zach F**a, who worked with me on a lot of
the cancer work, and Hope Arguela and Carter Norton, who worked on a lot of the
methylation studies with me.
Thanks so much.
Hi. You mentioned regions of the genome enriched for short
fragments. Have you understood what that means to be
enriched for a short fragment?
What is the content of short fragments relevant to relative to long fragments?
Sure. So I didn't talk about this in this study specifically,
but a lot of our work has shown that regions of the genome that are either related
to actively transcribing genes or open chromatin states are more likely to
originate short fragments, and this has to do with sort of selective degradation in
the circulation. So that's probably one of the reasons why these uniquely
unmethylated sites are originating short fragments.
But it was interesting that they came not just from all unmethylated sites in
the genome, but specifically from these cell type populations that we
identified to be altered in individuals with cirrhosis.
Cool. Thanks.
I have a question. Were you able to
use the cirrhosis,
I guess, signature
to see if any of those individuals went on to
develop hepatic cancer later so that you could
say that your signature was able to predict the people
who actually went on to get cancer?
Or do you have samples like that, like sequentially collected
during cirrhosis phase and during cancer in the same individuals?
Yeah. So this is a really interesting question.
We did not do that in this study, but I think it's a highly relevant question given
that there's a lifetime risk of about 30% of developing liver
cancer in individuals with cirrhosis.
And we've shown in other clinical settings that this type of fragmentomic approach
can be used to monitor patients over time, both for development and recurrence
of cancer.
Were you able to look at differences in causes of cirrhosis and
how it performed or if there was
variation?
Yeah. So in the full study, we described
different populations of patients that had viral hepatitis origins, both
hepatitis B and hepatitis C, as well as steatotic and metabolic liver
disease. And I think that broadly speaking, the etiologies of liver disease are
really quite variable, and the clinical need for diagnostics and the right
performance characteristics really do depend on the setting that you're seeing
these patients in. So this is definitely a focus of future trials.
Thank you. That was excellent.
Our pre-doctoral presenters are doing just excellently today.
And so our next speaker is Dr. Bergamaschi.
Thanks to the organizer for giving us the opportunity to talk about our
liquid biopsy approach for the early detection of pancreatic cancer.
So here is my disclosure slide.
And I will just jump into the clinical challenge.
Pancreatic cancer is very well known as a high mortality cancer.
It's projected to be the second leading cause of
death
by 2030.
And the five-year pancreatic cancer survival is 3%
when cancer is detected at late stages, but really jumps to
80% or greater if
the cancer is detected in early stage, especially stage 1A.
So here is the
unfortunate thing is that, and the challenge is that most of the cancer are
detected in late stages. And really, this is due to the fact that
there is an overall lack of early detection methods, but
also a lack of strategy approach for the surveillance of
individuals at high risk for pancreatic cancer.
It's well known that individuals with genetic mutation and
comorbidities have increased risk for pancreatic cancer.
Individuals that have hereditary syndromes like BRCA
mutations or Lynch syndrome, have familial
pancreatic cancer. They are at a moderate to high risk for the
disease. But those individuals that have neonate diabetes have
higher risk
for pancreatic cancer, and these individuals really need
early detection. Current guidelines really only call
out surveillance for individuals that have hereditary syndrome
or familial history and leave out some of other
high-risk patients that probably need as well to be
surveilled. So more work needs to be done on
that.Our test was specifically developed
to target these individuals at high risk for pancreatic
cancer and really is covering this different population
that you see in this slide. And in the
next slide that I'm going to show you, I'm going to call out the makeup of this
high risk across our cohorts, including the training cohort
and the validation cohorts.
Now, if we think about our core technology, it's based on
the 5-hydroxymethylcytosine.
5-hydroxymethylcytosine is a stable epigenomic mark that
is very distinct from the 5-methylcytosine.
It's strongly associated with active genome
and
5 ;-HMC patterns can be measured in cell-free DNA.
And this is really giving us the opportunity not only to look at the cell-free DNA
coming from tumor cells, but also leverage the signal coming
from immune cells, microenvironment, giving us the
opportunity to look more comprehensively to the
cancer biology itself.
This slide shows the 5-HMC
as a powerful biomarker.
In the heat map, you can see there are two
different sections. There is a cancer tissue section and a normal
tissue.
The powerful
things that 5-HMC has is that it can distinguish cancer
type, as you can see on the top part of the heat map.
There are very distinct pattern, for example, breast, colorectal,
lung, ovarian, and so on. But also you can actually
distinguish not only between cancer tissue, but also across normal
tissue. And you can see here there is a clear signal coming just from
the normal breast, normal colon, lung, et cetera.
I'm not showing it here, but actually this tissue signature are
recapitulated in blood, and this is one of the reason why we think
this approach is very valuable for liquid biopsy.
On top of the 5-hydroxymethylcytosine, we are also
looking at the fragment size, as you heard from the previous speaker,
as a contributing feature in cancer detection.
As you know, shorter cell-free DNA are associated with cancer, and we
actually have a very efficient way to look at both the fragment
size and the 5-HMC almost in one go.
And I can show you this in these slides.
So we start from the whole blood, we process to plasma.
From plasma, we obtain 10 nanogram of cell-free DNA that enters the library
preparation.
The library preparation starts with the whole genome library.
A small fraction is used to be sequenced, and that gives the
information of the fragment size, and then the remaining is actually
used for the 5-HMC enrichment. The
enrichment have four different steps.
Starts with the glucosylaton, which is an enzymatic addition of the
glucose to the 5-HMC residue. It's followed by
biotinylation, which is done with the click chemistry,
enrichment with streptavidin, and finally amplification with
PCR and then sequencing.
Additionally to the 5-HMC, the fragment size, we are
also looking at CA19-9. CA19-9
is very well commonly used marker in pancreatic cancer.
It's not used for screening, but it's used for monitoring of the
disease.
We are using the CA19-9 in a very unique way.
We are measuring
using an immunoassay, but then we are adjusting the level of
the CA19-9 based on the food genotyping
levels.
So we adjust the CA19-9, and then we use the CA19-9
adjusted level to give rise to what we
call the tumor specific lichen signature, which is
basically using the value of CA19-9 as an interaction
term for the 5-hydroxymethylcytosine and the fragment size.
All these three different features that we can obtain from each samples that
we process are used to generate what we call
our classification algorithm. Going through machine
learning that really selects, based on the complementarity of
these features, the best features to discriminate between pancreatic
cancer and non-cancer.
So how we built our model was based on more than
1,000 samples, 116 pancreatic cancer,
983 non-cancers, and here are the different
high-risk individuals. We included individuals with family history,
new onset diabetes, diabetics, heavy smokers.
From all of these patients, again, we obtained these features, the
5-HMC, the fragment size, the tumor
specific lichen signature, fed into
the machine learning that leveraged this
way of complementarity of the features and came up with a classification
algorithm to then classify each specific sample
with a signal detected or non-detected.
This is the performance of the training cohort,
and you can see we were targeting high sensitivity while
maintaining high specificity. And in this cohort, we
saw 80.5% overall sensitivity,
75.5% early stage sensitivity, and a
specificity of 97.5%.
All of these performance value hit our target profile
and we then went on and validated further.
But before we moved into the validation set-I also wanted
to note that we were very curious to see which features were
actually selected by the model. So rather than leave it as a black box,
we really wanted to understand if any biology was
recapitulated. So we ran actually a pathway analysis of
all the features selected, and we saw that those features that were
selected were actually identifying genes
that were involved in hall markers of cancer.
And you can see they were actually all hitting the
different hallmarks.
And we found that that's actually quite interesting because we didn't
pre-specify any pathways of any sort.
So the model itself was able to
recapitulate meaningful biological information.
But now let's look at how the model can
actually perform an independent data set in samples that it has not seen
before.
So we interrogated our model in 1,445 samples,
259 cancer, and more than 1,000 non-cancer.
We included different individuals with different level of risk for
pancreatic cancer. And on the right-hand side, you can see the performance of
the test, 82.6% overall
sensitivity, 76.8%
early-stage sensitivity, and maintain the same high specificity
of 97.5%, confirming again that the cross-validation
performance was recapitulated in this large, independent,
high-risk cohort.
Now, this was one cohort. Obviously, you want to see that repeated
across different cohort sets. So we added two more
cohorts with different high-risk makeup.
We have a validation number two, which we really enrich for those
individuals with new onset type 2 diabetes.
And then we had another cohort, cohort number three,
with some other high-risk individuals, including,
again, the heavy smoker and long-standing diabetes.
Here is the performance across all the three data sets.
I've shown you the validation one, and here's the
performance for the validation set two and validation set three.
And overall, there is no significant difference in performance across
the validation cohorts.
One important aspect of developing a test is
really understanding the specificity of the test.
So we wanted to understand if there were other cancer, how would the test
behave and really test our specificity against
11 different cancer type. These cancer type are all shown here
on the x-axis,
and we have seen that overall, the total impact on
specificity was only reduced by less than
0.05%. So our base specificity was
97.5%. The adjusted
specificity was 97.45%, really
highlighting that the test and the model was very specific for
pancreatic cancer rather than other cancers.
This slide is really a comprehensive look of how the test
end-to-end works. It starts again, as I mentioned, from a whole
blood. From whole blood, we obtain plasma.
At the plasma step, we actually divide the analytical path in
two parallel path, one that evaluates the
CA19-9 level and then another one that is specific for
the next generation sequencing workflow.
As I mentioned, both these analytical pathways give rise
to the feature definition that are used by the classification
algorithm that scores each samples with a
qualitative signal non-detected or signal detected.
If a signal is detected, then clinical management is highly
advised and especially diagnostic imaging as a follow-up.
One thing that I wanted to mention is that this workflow is fully automated,
starting from the plasma
all the way through the sequencing, and the workflow and the lab is
CLIA and CAP certified.
In conclusion, I've shown you that
our multi-analyte liquid biopsy platform combines five HMC
signatures, cell-free DNA fragment size, and these personalized
CA19-9 levels.
I've also shown you that the model that we have developed that is running
behind the test is actually biologically
meaningful and is hitting all the different hallmarks of cancer.
The test has a quite robust performance across different
cohorts. Early stage sensitivity is
76.8%, overall sensitivity 82.6%,
and a high specificity of 97.5%.
I also mentioned it's a simple blood draw.
It's an easy clinical implementation, for example, for
surveillance in high-risk population.
The blood doesn't need to be specifically handled, can be shipped at room
temperature to our lab, and we can then take it from
there and report back to the physician.
This was my last slide, so I'm happy to take any questions.
Sorry.
Okay, I'm going to ask one question, Well.
So what is the plan for prospective validation?
So I didn't have the time to show that,
but we do have several clinical ongoing
trials that are looking at prospective and
longitudinal collected samples that will be...
score with our test. We have some that are interventional
studies. So soon we should have an idea of how the test performs,
not just in a case control, but also in a pre-diagnostic setting.
So that's probably where the test needs to be shown its
utility.
I just had a quick question. Do you
see any potential value in using this for also MRD or
following patients who've been treated and diagnosed with pancreatic
cancer?
Yes, that's definitely a venue that we are exploring.
We know the technology can do that.
We haven't tested with this version of the test, but itself, the
5-hydroxymethylcytosine can be used to track,
actually tumor burden, and we have a paper on lung cancer that can show
that, especially in
relation to treatment.
Got it. Thank you.
Thank you so much for your talk. Is there any
role in combining your liquid biopsy-based test with ongoing
work that is happening in the field of CT scans and AI
algorithms to predict pancreatic cancer risk?
And my second question is, we commonly see patients with IPMN that
need to be followed as well. Is that a group of patients that you have
included or are planning to include in your prospective validation?
So I'll reply to your second question, which is related to the
IPMNs. That is a very important population to us.
We are evaluating that. We just need bigger numbers, but some of the data
is quite encouraging. So we hope that with bigger numbers, we can support
that. And related to your first question, we are
evaluating our test, together with
imaging in one of the clinical trials that I mentioned.
So hopefully we'll know how that is going to work out and how it can be
integrated.
Thank you.
Very quick one. Do you have decoupled numbers for stage one
exclusively instead of bundling into stage one, two?
Yeah. So the sensitivity for
stage one was between 60% and going up to
70%, depending on the cohort.
Thanks.
Very quick
question. This sensitivity and specificity are really great.
Do you have any rough estimate of positive prediction value if
you apply this model to the external prospective study?
Mm-hmm. Yeah. So
we have done some of the simulation, assuming
the incidence within that population.
So if you just assume you have a 3% incidence, we are
estimating around 43% PPV.
Quickly ask you, so
there's two major cancer subtypes of pancreatic cancer,
PDAC and the PNET. So is there any kind of difference between
them regarding the sensitivity and specificity?
We haven't looked specifically at the PDAC and
PNET. The test is mainly PDAC. We do have a large
cohort of PNET that we are in the process of evaluating, so hopefully we'll
have some performance results coming out soon.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you.
Okay, short wrap up.
Thank you, to all the presenters, and congratulations
for really excellent presentations.
And also special thanks to those who got us your talks in advance.
Thank you to my co-chair, Dr. Melissa.
And,
also to ACR for having an increasing focus on prevention,
which obviously I don't need to say to this audience, is a really
important part of our cancer research.
These are my disclosures.
And I just thought I would put into context the presenters today and where they
kind of fit into this continuum of prevention,
which
starts with risk assessment and developing more precise
mechanisms of risk assessment that include
genetics, family history, exposures, things like breast density,
et cetera.
And then primary prevention, which can include many things, including
lifestyle changes, vaccines, risk reducing strategies,
surgical prevention,
and then early detection, which we heard about,
including screening and surveillance.
And then interception, which is just a fancy word that we like to throw around now,
which is basically the interruption of
neoplastic progression, before you
get to a frank malignancy. And that can include both primary prevention, such
as vaccines, et cetera, or
early detection.
And so it fits into both of those areas.
So most of the talks we heard about today were really about precision
risk assessment, and that's just a critical first step if we're going to have
effective tailored prevention and interception.
You're hearing more and more about multimodal risk assessment and using the power
of AI to integrate many factors.
And
recently the first FDA-approved
AI-powered risk assessment using mammography was added to
NCCN guidelines. So now we're really rapidly going
from discovering these new risk assessments into integrating them
into clinical care, and that's really exciting.
Accurate risk assessment is critical to tailored, and
cost-effective, and equitable precision prevention and
interception.
So,
I'm not going to go through these exactly in order, a little bit more,
having to do with the continuum. But we heard, from Sridhar et al.
about somatic APC mosaicism that's associated with classical
pathogenic variants, while non-mosaic cases had more of the
colibactin-producing bacteria associated,
and mosaicism is super interesting.
We're all mosaic, reallyAnd then
we heard in another-- You could also call clonal
hematopoiesis a version of somatic mosaicism, but
therapy-related myeloid neoplasia and developing more precise risk
assessment for that from Barnao et al., looking at
therapy-associated clonal hematopoiesis, and then the risk of hematologic
malignancy after primary cancer therapy,
and that was pretty fascinating.
So then, I didn't think I
spelled that right, sorry, Abubakar et al.,
we saw a single-cell pathology
in normal breasts revealed occult signatures that signal an increased
cancer risk that was subtype specific.
And one of the really remarkable things I thought about this talk was
the involvement of
normal, not cancer survivors, but just healthy
advocates
without cancer who donated normal breast tissue to this really
large biobank, and the power of that community-based
partnership and what
we can get from that. So just that
is just a very impressive and precious resource.
So then we heard from Annapragada et al.
on the early detection of liver disease.
So to more precisely define
at-risk individuals,
provides an opportunity for primary prevention and early detection.
There was a recent publication
that I'd like to highlight that you guys should see.
And then
we moved on to some early detection, and
Advani et al. presented deep plasma
proteomics for the early detection for breast cancer with a focus on
people with dense breast tissue. So this idea of
developing specific early detection for
at-risk populations kind of combines these themes.
And then early detection for pancreatic cancer.
So that is like a steep mountain to climb, the
early detection of pancreatic cancer, so kudos to
Bermasiki? I'm sorry
about that, et al. for attacking that.
And I just want to say for anybody who are reviewers for grant
applications, don't diss the early
detection just because they're hard to detect cancers.
Don't give up on that. We're moving into a new era, and we should
get rid of some of our old skepticism as we are using new techniques.
So multi-analyte liquid biopsy for the early detection of pancreatic
cancer utilizing epigenomics, genomics, and CA19-9
combination
gives us hope for some of these hard-to-detect cancers.
And then finally,
DeWitt et al. showed that
the impact of patient biology on racial disparities in breast cancer outcomes
can provide insight into risk stratification and potentially
new primary prevention opportunities.
So understanding tumor biology is very important to lead to
more equitable precision prevention in addition to therapies.
So,
just thank you guys for taking on these hard tasks.
The difficult trail is sometimes the most rewarding,
and I'm glad that we have adventurous
researchers and early investigators that are carrying
us forward.
So this precision prevention continuum is
really
obviously utilizing a lot of machine learning and AI
techniques to
put together many different kinds of analytes, et cetera, and I think that it's
opening a massive
new door of optimism for cancer prevention.
Anybody in this room, if you're an AACR member, you
can join any of the working groups at no cost.
So if anybody's here and not a part of the Cancer Prevention work group, you should
be, because just by being here, you've indicated your interest.
And the town hall for the Cancer Prevention work group is
tonight at 6:30,
and it's in combination with the Immunology work group.
It's going to be Immunology Precision Prevention, which is going to
be super interesting. And of course, there's drinks and some food afterwards,
so come to that. And that's really
it. I would just want to, again, thank you, and thank you to the audience for
your really engaged participation, which I think made it a
really interesting session.